this is the man
doctors in india are holding a national
day of protest against
yoga guru and businessman baba ramdev is
promoting his herbal formula called
coronal to fight the coronavirus
while blaming modern medicine for
india's high number of covered 19
deaths and that's prompted doctors to
launch their protest
in a country like india where people
tend to follow spiritual gurus
yoga gurus and that too blindly
uh when people like that they spread
mistrust
misinformation it becomes very difficult
for us
as you know science based people as
doctors to
wipe that misinformation out
doctors are taking part in what they're
calling a black day by turning their
social media profile pictures
into a black background this group of
doctors has gathered here to call for
government action against ramdev
they say he's taking advantage of the
pandemic and his large public following
to persuade people to buy his unapproved
and dubious products
health minister attended the launch of
coronal that ramdev claims prevents
treats and cures covert 19. vardhan is
the chair of the executive board of the
world health organization
or wh ramdev has claimed coronal was
approved by the global body
but the who denies that a senior
journalist who had his
car ties slashed while investigating
ramdev's business interests
claims he's protected by the government
his vested interest in businesses uh
which is really what he is
uh behind the sham of
being a yogi uh have seen and it's been
documented to some extent
uh just completely concomitant with the
rise of the government
so in some sense he has a political
sanction
[Music]
ramdev spokesperson didn't respond to al
jazeera's request for an interview
but the guru counts millions of indians
as followers including anil sabarwal
who sells his range of products called
patanjali
i don't sell patanjali products just for
business this is a matter of faith guru
ramdev
shows us the way i had some ailments but
the moment i started hearing his sermons
the healing process had already begun
many people in india have a deep trust
in gurus and alternative medicine
but many doctors say ramdev's claims
can't be substantiated
and he must be held to account for her
statements especially
during a pandemic elizabeth puranam al
jazeera new delhi